[Musique]
bonjour géraldine de très beaux jours
vous êtes du collectif matinik contre
marine le pen vous avez rappelé les
objectifs de ce collectif avant-hier une
quinzaine d'organisations politiques
associatives 6 3e féministes qui disent
non au programme de marine le pen car
dites-vous il ne faut pas laisser les
idées racistes et xénophobes repris dans
notre île oui c'est à dire que
dernièrement
visiblement il ya des gens ici qui
pensent que le parti de marine le pen
est un parti comme les autres
c'est pas vrai il suffit j'invite les
auditeurs et les auditrices à aller
regarder les noms des gens qui
l'entourent et là on voit clairement que
ce sont tous des gens qui ont passé deux
d'extrême droite qui alors y'a pas je
vous hais les groupuscules occident le
guide dernièrement alex loustau et
frédéric chatillon qui sont tous les
deux membres du front national est
proche de marine le pen sont allés
féliciter les noms delgrès qui est un
ancien combattant de la waffen ss qui
est pro néo nazis en un système dédicace
de son livre enfin c'est des gens qui
sont clairement raciste et moins de 24
heures après la conférence de presse de
votre collectif samedi dernier il ya
juvénal rémir qui est connu ici en
martinique dans le milieu agricole et
politique à voter entre autres à l'ex
ump et il parle devant des mots pas très
élogieux un comité qui ne représente
rien comité et là on va volontairement
arrondir les angles
évitez de le citer directement avec des
mots creux qu'ils ont caractérisé ce
goût là il parle de comités de personnes
en souffrance affective
bon alors je veux même pas répondre ça
n'a aucun intérêt jeu juste note qu'il
s'était 4 que nous sommes seize donc
c'est pas un analyste nous sommes des
mouvements de foule ou enfin 4 16 mais
je vais pas jouer de charitables soyons
chrétiens et chrétiennes
donc voilà par contre moi je vais dire
quelque chose de clair à monsieur
rémy c'est ça et je juge alain ribeyre
oui j'ai même du mal à retenir son
prénom série son nom donc ce monsieur
qui dit que pas de souci les antilles ne
sont pas dans le collimateur de marine
le pen
je rappelle que le front national c'est
vous savez quand vous appartenez un
parti qu'on fait des recherches vous
savez que en général les partis de
gauche comme les partis de droite leurs
membres ont un passé qui en général est
en accord avec ce qu ils font soit ils
se sont radicalisées soit ils ont mille
l'eau dans leur vin
mais on est rarement changé de camp donc
je suis en train d'expliquer je voudrais
que les auditeurs et les auditrices le
sache clairement que l'extrême droite
française elle a trois axes est là la
france défendre la souvenez la
souveraineté donc d'une france blanche
d'une france chrétienne et d'une france
souveraine
je vais m'attacher aux deux premiers
blanche c'est le premier cas importants
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
monsieur rémire comme moi même ne sommes
pas blanc et il faut qu'ils comprennent
que c'est pas parce que sa boulangère
lui dit bonjour avec le sourire qu'elle
a un qu'elle a des sentiments pour lui
c'est pas parce que madame le pen elle
veut lui vendre son pain exactement
comme madame le pen madame le pen ce pas
parce qu'elle lui serre la main qu'elle
le considère comme un français au même
titre qu'elle est que les choses sont
dites clairement et ça se reflète dans
son programme non martiniquais nous
caribéen
voilà nous ne pouvons pas nous retrouver
selon vous dans les tasses de madame le
pen
non parce qu elles vont à l'encontre de
nos intérêts même si on n'est pas dans
les dents la solidarité dans le fait
qu'il faut s'ouvrir au monde et c'est
même sans aller dans des idées aussi
importante 1 mais général et de façon
extrêmement égoïste en tant qu'hommes et
femmes noires nous sommes directement
menacés
monsieur rémy rssi mais le front
national parce je le préviens qui risque
un jour de se retrouver arrêté par un
policier qui viendra de métropole et qui
lui dira ah bon alors bambou l'armement
de ses papiers et qui dira après comme
on connaît le papier la duration non
parce que c'est un p c'est un parti qui
dit clairement que la france est une
france blanche
nous sommes des colonisés nous sommes
des citoyens et des citoyennes de
seconde zone et ça se reflète dans le
programme politique alors je ne sais pas
ce que monsieur rémy refait s'il a lu le
programme de moi je les lui est par
exemple surtout photographions salon de
l'agriculture avec m voilà c'est ça mais
je vais dire que alors je vais compenser
que ce monsieur est honnête et que ce
monsieur est un peu aveugle et mais je
vais pas mal à lui prêter comme
les mains de marine le pen en disant aux
marines ceci marine soldats de l'apl
très affectueusement par son prénom
or pour l élite intègre un programme qui
s'il oublie pas quoi un froid les thèses
de marine le pen serait dangereuse pour
nos populations métisses et vous évoquez
un projet sociétal qui pourrait remettre
beaucoup de choses en question pour nous
les évolutions possibles pour la
jeunesse le développement économique
oui absolument par exemple pour vous
donner un exemple donc d'abord c'est
tout s'est tourné vers le colonialiste
puisque france blanche chrétienne
souveraine dont c'est l'état colonial et
la liste des candidats oui mais là où il
attendait non c'est pas la même place
même souveraineté
là il ya une tendance à considérer que
les pays d'outre-mer d'ailleurs le
premier chose qu'elle fait c'est
transformé le ministère de l'outre-mer
au ministère de l'outre-mer et de la mer
les choses en sont claires c'est à dire
que la mère position ressources
économiques et position stratégique la
martinique en tant que tel ça n'a aucune
importance c'est le principe du
colonialisme c'est à dire qu'on
développe un territoire qui vous
appartient non pas pour le développement
en soi de ce territoire et de ses
populations
mais dans la mesure où il sert le
colonisateur c'est à dire la métropole
et à gauche chez les populations
bah oui c'est à dire que ça n'a aucune
importance est pas le propos je vous le
dis quand même pour les pour l'économie
et pour l'emploi elle envisage de créer
des zones ultra marine française
d'investissement prioritaire ça veut
dire quoi quand on regarde son programme
et va faire venir elle va favoriser
l'arrivée de capitaux étrangers et de
capitaux métropolitan avec aucune
garantie de l'emploi local mais surtout
ce que ça va être long feu oui
absolument mais s'est calmé créer une je
suis d'accord avec vous mais là vous
avez derrière un parti donc à une
idéologie raciste à dire qu'ils ne
comptent nous considèrent pas compte des
français à part à parts égales on ait
des français de seconde zone
monsieur rémy ressemble un arabe il faut
qu'ils le sachent à dire que est comme
moi d'ailleurs comme vous on peut on est
on est noir mais on a quand même des
aussi beaucoup d tête d'arabe
en gros nous ne faisons pas partie des
vrais français enfin dernièrement je
rappelle qu'il ya une élue qui voulaient
d'origine kabyle qui s'est présentée qui
voulait se présenter un autre accident
de vaucluse et qui a renoncé a rendu sa
carte en disant que derrière la façade
audible
boulangère jean ramel l'analogie la
boulangère qui vous vendent dans leur
votre sont pas derrière il ya un
discours ouvertement raciste donc ça va
à l'encontre de notre intérêt et en tant
que femme
oui justement plus spécifique pour la
situation de la fin puisque rappelons le
vous êtes l'une des composantes de ce
collectif vous êtes également de
l'association culture égalité
associations féministes en croit c'est
le programme du le programme frontiste
serait dangereux pour les femmes
oui alors dans ce collectif il ya deux
associations sur cèze ya deux
associations féminisme culture égalité
l'union des femmes c'est pas un hasard
marine le pen qui a revêtu les habits de
la de la féministe dit clairement que
son objectif entre autres c'est de
réduire un certain nombre d'allocations
de favoriser dont les zones planning
familial les choses comme ça mais
surtout de favoriser le retour des
femmes à leur foyer
quand on sait que le travail le travail
des femmes c'est quelque chose qui leur
a apporté l'autonomie qui fondamentale
en martinique elle touche que 65% en
moyenne de la retraite et martiniquaise
touche 65% en moyenne de la retraite des
martiniquais si vous êtes revenu si vous
revenez dans votre foyer
si votre mari vous quitte civ quand vos
enfants grandissent la location se
terminera vous ferez quoi 40 ans quand
vos enfants seront grands donc ça veut
dire que c'est pour augmenter la
précarité des femmes de façon
extrêmement clair en martinique à plus
de femmes que d'hommes
mesdames qui ne m'écoutait soyez
attentive là encore ça va vous êtes
doublement pénalisés par les thèses du
front national et par les programmes du
fonds national et en tant que noir vous
n'êtes pas blanche la croix celtique et
les votants 7 n'était enfin peut-être ya
longtemps des francs et des celtes
c'est très dilué 1 et puis par ailleurs
vous êtes une femme donc on va vous
inviter à rentrer dans vos foyers avec
tout ce que ça implique
on va citer que ça on va encore cité
lainière juvénal qui dit que selon lui
ces thèses frontistes gagne du tir est
que beaucoup de gens l'appellent mais
bon tout le monde peut le prétendre
mais que beaucoup de gens l'appellent on
regarde les chiffres lors de la dernière
présidentielle il y a quand même des
personnes qui se disent proches du front
national qui se disent tout simplement
on a essayé la droite ça n'a pas marché
on a essayé la gauche ça ne marche pas
faire nous allons voter pour quelqu'un
d'autre qui arrivera avec quelque chose
de nouveau
elle a d'abord ce n'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose de
très anciens c'est des programmes au
contraire le principe qui va pouvoir
ajouter aux propos mais le principe du
front national c'est comme tous les
mouvements
réactionnaire de revenir en arrière donc
c'est linverse de la modernité revenir à
une france traditionnel donc je rappelle
j'insiste encore lourdement une france
coloniale je vous invite à lire son
programme qui extrêmement succinct pour
l'outre-mer mais qui est extrêmement
clair c'était les gens en ont assez
madame dottore de quoi on a essayé
auparavant et qui n'a pas fonctionné ils
se disent pourquoi ne pas lui donner sa
chance mais le programme va donner
beaucoup de sympathisants de personnes
qui se disent proches de marine le pen
c'est ce qu'ils avancent comme argument
oui mais en fait ils vont se tirer une
balle dans le pied des falaises après
qu'on ne sait à oui mais notre travail
nous de militants et militantes c'est de
leur dire maintenant mais qu' ils se
retrouveront je ne plaisante pas quand
ils vont se retrouver on va avoir
économiquement son programme va ne pas
favoriser l'emploi local c'est pas son
objectif c'est une c'est une dîme ans et
un programme colonialiste à dire que ça
ne c'est le développement est lié à la
métropole tout et les instances
politiques donc c'était amadieu
improbablement je veux dire c'est quand
même on regarde les institutionnels ou
bien regarder comme ça mais je vous
ferai remarquer qu' il essaie en tout
cas il va y avoir des politiques
extrêmement de notre marché c'est le
marché caribéen et c'est le marché
américain c'est pas la métropole
notre marché naturel parce qu'un point
de vue économique pour l'instant même
sur mon envie de se tourner davantage de
la grippe s'est pas encore le cas
franches mais ça ne marche pas les flux
un peu le mythe et qui s'organise et ne
fonctionne pas regardez le coût de la
vie ici vous trouvez qu'on a un pouvoir
d'achat qui est important parce que
l'intérêt n'est pas de développer le
territoire c'est de développer le
commerce entre ce territoire et la
métropole
c'est totalement intéressés donc faut
arrêter ça aussi le comité marine
d'hervé vu le jour il y a deux ans il
est devenu un collectif contre contre
marine le pen vous allez être plus
visible plus actifs au cours des
prochains jours jusqu'au premier tour de
la campagne présidentielle jusqu'au
deuxième tour
vous iriez manifestation nous invitons
une manifestation le 25 marche
pour ce pour protester seul objectif de
lutter contre la montée du front
national ou de pousser un autre candidat
non il ya aucun objectif de pousser un
candidat l'objectif est de lutter contre
les idées nauséabondes du front national
qui sont contraires à notre intérêt
c'est extrêmement simple et que c'est
une honte je considère que cette femme
viennent en martinique ça veut dire que
ces thèses racistes etc sont audibles
attendait mais non mais mais plus qu'à
sur le sort et c'est tout le problème
c'est à dire que c'est de la poudre aux
yeux c'est le loup en habit de moutons
c'est il faut pas se livrer c'est
derrière je vous rappelle ses copains
qui vont voir le néo nazis donc que non
sa venue est un symbole qui est
inacceptable c'est une insulte à césaire
fans enfin tous les gens qui sont
dressés merci d'avoir été avec nos
jeunes à l'aise de curieux rappelle que
vous êtes du collectif contre marine le
pen verse davantage de bonnes c'est moi
qui vous remercie
[Musique]